foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah happy Monday everybody so you
know that family from your old
neighborhood the family that if he got
into a fight with one of them you had to
watch your back for the rest of them
the cops are always at their house they
didn't seem to work at all you heard
they stole stuff they argued in public
they smelled
they had cars parked on their front lawn
and their pictures were on the post
office wall more than their high school
yearbooks they thought they were
but you knew that no matter what like an
SNL sketch it wasn't going to end well
for them or anyone dumb enough to get
involved with them so what happens when
that trashy family ends up living at
1600 Pennsylvania
[Applause]
thanks the clintons look like The
Waltons
so let's start with the thief in Chief
dad on Friday he finally acknowledged
his seventh granddaughter Hunter's
daughter with London Roberts this after
avoiding her like she was Kamala Harris
for some reason it came in an exclusive
statement to People magazine making it
their best scoop since they discovered
that love child I had with Angela
Lansbury
she was a hell of an animal but here's
what uh he said to a Ducey back in 2019.
Mr Vice President I'm wondering if you
have a comment on this report and Court
filing out of Arkansas that your son
Hunter just made you a grandfather again
no that's a private matter I have no
comment thank you
thank you classy yeah classy like
denying a kid's existence for four years
keep in mind that the bidens put up
Christmas stockings for their pets
and not one for this poor little brat
I mean that affectionately
I'm sorry but the only class Joe Knows
are the ones he lied about finishing at
the top of Joe
Joe's been stealing other people's
material for so long Abe Lincoln sent
him a cease and desist
you know Joe's pension for plagiarism
started at law school where he admitted
to lifting entire passages for a term
paper Syracuse law school punished him
by giving him an f and making him retake
the class that's right he was left back
in law school
I didn't know that was possible this
would be the law school where Joe says
he finished in the top half but it says
he finished 76 out of 85. so apparently
he sucks at math too
[Applause]
raises the question what kind of dope
would finish behind a doofus like Joe
back in
unnecessary but why not it's Monday back
in 1988 Joe's first presidential bid
cratered when he claimed his ancestors
were so tough they worked 12-hour days
in Coal Mines then came up and played
football turns out they were the
ancestors of a different politician one
in Britain and their version of football
was something called soccer a sport
Americans leave to children and Lady
people
I didn't make the rules
no Biden's ever worked in the coal mines
although once Jos did stay in a basement
for three months so maybe that counts
Joe also claimed to have his helicopter
forced down by Al Qaeda to have been
shot at in Iraq and to have been
arrested in civil rights demonstrations
including trying to visit Nelson Mandela
in jail
to be fair he did think Mandela was Corn
Pop
all those claims turned out to be about
as genuine as Joe's teeth
and last week Dr Jill Biden's ex-husband
Bill Stevenson went public stating that
Joe's brother Frank threatened that if
Jill didn't get the house and their
divorce Stevenson would face serious
problems but he hung onto the house and
was then hit with tax charges in
Delaware in Delaware a few months later
this would be the same Frank Biden who
by the way has been busted for DUI
driving without a license and for
shoplifting DVDs from a Florida video
shop let me guess it was Godfathers one
through three
and of course there's Biden's other
brother Jim part of the famous business
team of Jim and Hunter Hunter's laptop
the filthiest thing since Charlie
Sheen's toilet seat
reveals that Uncle Jim's always been
part of this game in 2018 as Hunter's
dealings with a corrupt Chinese oil
became public
Uncle Jim was frantically texting Hunter
to call him and to help him play out
these deals according to the Washington
Post this Chinese Communist Party linked
oil firm paid Hunter and his uncle
nearly 5 million in just over a year I
wonder what Hunter did with all that
money
I'm sure he invested it wisely in stock
so though according to his laptop picks
this guy had more pipes in his mouth
than an Indian chief
Native American of course Uncle Jim and
Hunter know about us know about as much
about oil as cat does hammer curls
and uncle Jim's daughter Caroline is a
rising family star she's also been
arrested for DUI driving without a
license and as well as you guessed it
felony shoplifting here at NYC is that
kind of now some kind of family
tradition
hey who's stealing the Thanksgiving
turkey this year kids
she's also been arrested for attacking
the police and resisting arrest she
looks adorable not to be outdone Joe
Biden's own daughter Ashley has a rap
sheet for drug possession and attempting
to interfere with cops while they were
making an arrest in a brawl and then
there's Hunter
this show is only an hour
no forget about that Chinese oil deal
with Uncle Jim or the barisma deal in
which he had another Oil Company
Ukrainian paid him Millions for his
non-expertees and forget about the fact
that the wife of moscow's longtime mayor
reportedly sent Hunters firm upwards of
100 million over the years yeah and
Trump's in agent of Russia
I forget the drugs and the prostitutes
wow if I had a nickel every time I said
that
but here's a guy who took up with his
dead brother's ex-wife who he promptly
cheated on he denied fathering a baby he
knew was his and he forced that baby's
mother to accept a few of his crap
paintings his child support when John
Wayne Gacy's art was far better
he's even denied the kid use of his name
which given his family's history maybe
the one break this kid has gotten
I wonder what Joe thinks
no no no look look I I know about this
girl the uh I just lost track that's all
six seven uh I don't know much about
hunter's professional or private life I
mean uh I run into him on a golf course
every once in a while that's about it
but uh no no she's great and uh I hope
this kid comes to visit at the White
House I'll find her a job to do uh you
know if I uh stumble getting off a plane
you know maybe she could help out you
know that'll be her job
visiting grandchild she'll pick you up
off the tarmac
wet and welcome tonight's guest if
you're afraid of crowds spread out and
get comfy at one of his shows actor
writer and comedian Jamie listow
player communication skills give
liberals the chills communications
director at Never Back Down back Aaron
perini
this x cop did everything by the book
unfortunately that book was are you
there God it's me Margaret that outer of
the office desk.org Paul Morrow
finally she's like a zipper people tend
to notice her when she's down
Fox News contributor captive
Jamie want to point out first that you
and I will be performing together in
Reading Pennsylvania on September 16th
you can go to gee Godfather it's going
to be you and me and Nick depalo and Jim
Norton and Joe Mackey it's going to be a
lot of fun despite having you there
um
which ironic to me is that Hunter's
child wanted to be known as Hunter's
child but your children tell everyone
that their dad is dead
I don't know if that's ironic it's just
something to point out to make me feel
better yeah it's it's all I think it's
also sad
um you know I all the all the Joe lies
you're going through yeah at the
monologue don't you think Biden didn't
count on verification by Google yeah
like do you know what I mean like a lot
Google put a lot of out of business you
know you could say whatever you wanted
back then and nothing I did a deep dive
on this on the Hunter and um when they
is it fun when you're reading about
Hunter they said the mom of the child
was a dancer right isn't it fun that
when you read something about Hunter and
it says the mom was a dancer you don't
go oh ballet or what I wonder what kind
of
it's for sure a stripper uh
ironically her finishing move was the
Nutcracker
see with your jokes there's always a
search to step in you know in the middle
of it because it takes forever but it's
always worth it oh thank you yes
thank you sort of
I mean I was thinking about this is the
president he called seven well six or
seven grandchildren he says he calls his
grandchildren every day and I was like
he's got time for that man because
they're all going to voicemail
it's quicker yeah that was good I
couldn't interrupt Aaron you know uh why
do you think he decided to acknowledge a
grandchild do you think it had anything
to do with polling I mean there's
certainly speculation it's not a good
look right he's built this political
ideology and uh you know people believe
that he's this great family man this
great grandfather and then he's got this
secret seventh child that he'll never
acknowledge but really they hit the
trifecta on a political news dump it was
a Friday afternoon in the summer and
he's heading out for a Beach vacation
he's not going to have to take questions
on this for 10 days while he's gone so
this was just them trying to yet again
sweep this under the rug I'm sure the
polling doesn't look good when you have
denied a grandchild for four years can't
imagine anybody's super supportive on
that one yeah going to the beach while
you just let that kid swelter in some
ungodly basement I'm made all of that up
we don't know if that's true
but I'd like to think that Paul uh
monologue was pretty strong tonight I
felt I felt so yeah yeah
we found out today that Joe was in on
all those phone calls with his son and
they claim people come they were only
talking about the weather when he would
bring his dad into the phone calls what
have you what do you make of that yeah
did you when you were a cop and you were
in meetings did other police officers
ever go hold on can my dad come in and
talk let me call my dad yeah we're
negotiating a plea dad are you free you
know you're the Commissioners is really
mad at me dad he killed his whole family
he buried him in the backyard but maybe
you can talk to this guy
20 times no less yeah first of all Devin
Archer didn't kill himself okay yeah
they're right to it now I mean because
he buried them today everybody has been
saying we need to witness somebody that
can say they were there and they Point
Blank witnessed it but you know let's
cut to the bottom here the guy so if Joe
Biden our president has a real estate
portfolio that's roughly equivalent to
like the British royal family and he's
been a career civil servant now you got
to say to yourself how did that happen
and then you got to say to yourself why
does it really matter to us aside from
the Integrity issues and everything else
you got the barisma deal right that's
Ukraine he comes back from Ukraine he
says I'm going to go after that
prosecutor he gets the prosecutor fired
100 million dollars come from the
mayor's wife in Moscow right that
oligarch never sanctioned okay the
Chinese situation right the oil thing
when you say to yourself I don't
understand why can't we be a little
tougher on China
is your answer and that's why it matters
not because of the money and everything
else sure that matters but what really
matters is we're all getting screwed
because he's supposed to be looking out
for us and that is in our policy that's
his policy that's his family's policy
that's the problem yeah and uh to your
point I mean who do they kept saying it
was Russia Russia Russia was Trump and
here's they've got a hundred million
dollars from the spouse of a mayor it
makes it's absolutely and where did it
go I mean on the laptop Hunter's always
crying poverty you can buy a lot of
crack with 100 million bucks lest I
checked not that I would know you know
he's trying to renegotiate his payments
for child support right now as well yeah
you got to bury that you can't be
bragging about that money if you want to
take it from your kid so cat it is Paul
makes a great point about how a civil
servant is going to end up richer than
all of us will ever be as a civil
servant and the whole point was using
that in order to get rich yeah aren't
you mad yes always
um well that like that's like a huge
part of the government I mean same thing
with I mean you want me to just list
everybody's name in the government we
don't have time for that
um but I the the grandchild thing look I
would never deny any of my grandchildren
no matter how much they suck yeah and
because you just can't that's not
something you can do and also the
grandkids whose parents are addicts a
lot of times the grandparents take care
of them I know this because I watch a
lot of intervention yeah hey hun a lot
of those grandparents have a lot fewer
resources than the leader of the Free
World exactly so I just don't understand
why it took so long because I don't know
how you wouldn't care but let's say you
don't if you've been in politics this
long shouldn't you be better at
pretending to Care by now that's true
you've oh you've you're like the Mr
Olympia of being phony yeah because you
have these your muscles for lying must
be massive yes just pretend at least but
couldn't be bothered to do that well I
know that I would definitely recognize
my grandchildren but not the children
just skip them
just deny but then recognize the
grandchildren just to piss off the the
rotten kids that I have that I've yet to
have they're still deciding not sure all
right before we go as I mentioned I got
a few extra friends and guest comedians
for the next stop on my book tour
including shalu lissau Norton Mackie
depaolo this is amazing it's like an
All-Star September 16th Reading PA go to
gutfeld.com for Ticket info up next
crime and filth are fine but not elon's
sign
if you'll be in the New York area and
would like free tickets to see Gutfeld
go to foxnews.com Gutfeld and click on
the link to join our studio audience
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else